Hey, I'm uh, Bob Saget. I know. Hold your applause. And, uh,
this is answer to the internet. That's what this is.
Here's a card.
We're in an open field. You can't right, dude.
We're an open field arm with a baseball bat.
How many ten-year-olds wearing bike helmets.
Could you take down before they got to you? That's funny.
I'm like Thor with my hammer. I would just take that bat and I would just,
and we would just go around and I wouldn't hurt the kids.
I'd knock the bikes out from under them. That's a teach them a lesson.
I don't know. I got a.
How many kids am I going to beat? I'm not going to beat kids.
I got my own children. I got TV kids all around me. They're not,
they didn't say they were like little gnomes or something.
Yeah. They're they're angry.
Well,
I'll pick up one kid and throw it at the other kid and knock them all over.
I got nothing. You got me. You got me. You asked me questions.
You would ask Lenny of mice and men. Okay. That's a book.
Would you rather watch your dad have sex with a a hundred year old man?
Or watch your mom kill someone? Actually,
those are both very attractive options because they're both passed on. So, um,
I think it doesn't really matter cause they're both gone. Uh, my dad,
my mother was a a hundred year old man. So, um, and,
and right when my dad and her had sex at a hundred, she passed on.
So I would say, please delete. This is your awesome.
I would throw my a hundred year old parents, a little kids. Um,
could you beat up Tom cruise? No, no. Cause, um,
I don't think I could cause he does his own stunts and I do mine,
but I would, I would, uh,
I would go on a spaceship with him to wherever he believes in.
If you have one person now, uh, narrate, do a play by play of you having sex.
Who would it be? It would be me.
Cause I do the voices like on the video show videos after dark, I'd be like, Oh,
look out. Oh, I'm finishing, you know, things like that. Oh mom get off of me.
Oh, I'm sorry, son, stuff like that. You know that everybody can relate to.
Uh, there are two buttons. One initially gives you 1 million, one.
It gives you 50 50 shot at 100 million. Which do you push?
Who writes these materialistic children? Um,
50, 50 shot. I don't, I don't gamble.
So I guess I would take the 1 million and give it right to charity.
That would stop these kinds of questions being asked. Uh,
if you were to be murdered, who is your most likely suspect? John Stamos? Um,
because he's jealous of my handsome, good looks.
A pigs orgasm lasts for over 30 minutes. I know, um,
a lion can have sex over 50 times per day. Tell me about it. Uh,
which would you rather be? I'd like to be an orgasming pig eaten by a lion.
Would you switch live with Tim? Teebo if you, if, if,
if you do, you have to remain, you can't right.
You can't go to school. How do you have a show?
Would you switch lives with Tim? Teebo uh, if you,
if you have to remain a Virgin and go to church, first thing. Uh, no, no, no.
So, uh, no, I wouldn't switch lives with anybody. I liked my life quite a lot,
except not at this moment. And I have to remain a Virgin a little bit to that.
I lost my virginity at negative four. Um, I lost it in the womb.
Uh, my mom, uh, nevermind, but it was a long contraption, uh,
and go to church. I would go to Notre Dame if I could do some work there, um,
and help put the things out and help people maybe
help some charities.
Would you rather have a Dick as your nose or a noses? Your Dick?
Definitely a noses. My Dick. Cause then you could blow my nose.
[Inaudible].
And I know what upset you, but I'm not on antibiotics,
but it's viral. Take them anyway. Kids.
If people tell you don't take antibiotics because it's not bacteria,
they're full of. Take drugs, no matter what and stay in school.
If you ended a beauty pageant, what would your talent be? Um,
I can make a hemorrhoid poke in and out of my butt. Um, I'm just kidding.
I can do it out of somebody else's but let's take that again.
If you entered a beauty pageant, what would your talent beat? Um,
it would be strangling the people filming this last question.
If there were stats available for every aspect of your life,
what one stat about yourself would you want to know? Um,
am I really a man? I don't think I want to ask that.
Uh, if they're awful quiet in here,
if there were stats available for every aspect of your life,
what one stat about yourself?
Would you want to know how many millimeters long as my team?
I just wanted to time. Graham.
Thank you so much. Thank you very much. I really appreciate.
It.